لطالما حظرت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من ان
التصديا لاي تواغل تركيا جديد سيحول
مواردها بعيدا عن مكافحه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه تحذيرات اصبحت اليوم واقعا على
الارض اوقفت قواتنا كل عمليات التنسيق
والعمليات المشتركه لمكافحه الارهاب مع
التحالف الذي تقوله الولايات المتحده
وكذلك جميع العمليات الخاصه المشتركه التي
كنا ننفذها بانتظام كما اكدت قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه عدم قدرتها على حمايه سجن
جويران الذي يضم اكبر عدد من مقاتلي تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه مطالبه موسكو باعلان
مواقف اكثر حزما لحتى تركيه على حل
الخلافات بالحوار لا بالحرب على روسيا ان
تتحمل مسؤوليه ايقاف التصعيد التركي على
المنطقه كونها دوله ضميره لاتفاق الوقف
اطلاق النار المتفق عليه مع تركيا الاكراد
وجهه رساله اخرى الى واشنطن يطالبون فيها
اقوى انتشار تعزيزات تركيه غير مسبوقه على
الحدود تعزيزات تقول انقر انها ضروري
لاستمرار عملتها والقضاء على اي نشاط لاي
تنظيم ارهابي في المنطقه